bonsoir merci d'être avec nous pour
cette dixième édition du drépaction le
concert annuel de lutte contre la
drépanocytose à l'appel de la pib dé
l'association pour l'information et la
prévention de la drépanocytose
il ya du rap avec ce cri ''j'avais que
pont peace avec sadek monthly nam hai el
merrikh carolina alors cette année notre
parrain n'est autre que kery james bond
bizarre et fier de l'être il n'est pas
condamné à l'échec
je vous entend chanter on y va
[Musique]
oh
on est là aussi pour faire la fête c'est
le but de cet événement c'est de parler
de la drépanocytose tout en faisant la
fête et c'est ce que tu veux
[Applaudissements]
jma n'en met à court d'idées pour tous
les jours on fait tous les genres je te
jure c'est dieu qui donne mais se
quittant le bus on bosse tous les jours
on fait tous les gens je te jure
c'est dieu qui donne maladie on n'en
parle pas assez
baverez pas de sitôt ça touche beaucoup
de jeunes comme moi comme comme nous
donc je compte sur vous pour aller faire
un bond sur le site ww points à ppd
point fr c'est important et on en a 13
ans